So, Monday is Independence Day.
Now, a lot of people
are gonna be celebrating--
fireworks, drinking.
Drinking fireworks.
Don't do that, by the way.
It's only a joke.
But, you know, it's funny,
every year I like to share
my reflections on the holiday
and country, and...
it's funny, I've been doing it
since the '70s, uh,
when I had my first show on UHF.
Did I ever mention that show?
In fact, you know,
I think we have some footage
from the big bicentennial
episode I did in '76.
Uh, Drake, can you run that?
♪ ♪
Hey, welcome back to my
Super Groovy Bicentennial BBQ
Can You Dig It? celebration.
So, Isaac from The Love Boat's
hanging with us today.
Uh, actually, um,
my name is Ted Lange.
-Mm-hmm. -Isaac is
just a character that I play.
Isaac, do that thing you do
on The Love Boat opening.
You know, with the fingers.
Do that.
That's some...
that's some cool (bleep).
Uh...
(laughs)
Yeah. All right, Isaac,
mix me up a mai tai.
Best Fourth of July I ever had,
I was butt-naked
on the George Washington Bridge.
-(chuckles)
-Um... that's where I woke up.
I don't know what hap...
That was the fifth of July.
What other holiday
can you do that? Arbor Day?
Go (bleep) yourself, Arbor Day.
You got to time your drugs
accordingly.
Nothing beats
some elephant tranquilizers
right before
the big fireworks display.
It adds three additional colors
not on the rainbow.
(chuckles):
You know what I'm saying?
And let me tell you
something, (bleep),
you never heard tuba music
till you've heard tuba music
on elephant tranquilizers.
That's some (bleep).
Nothing says Independence Day
like stepping away
from your marriage vows
and getting freaky
with the neighbor ladies.
You know what I mean. That's
independence, mother (bleep).
I'm talkin' wife-swappin'.
(chuckles):
Right? And free rides to the top
of Mount Washington Monument.
Why'd they call that thing
the Love Boat anyway?
Love is some
hippy-dippy (bleep), man.
People just want to bone.
They sh...they ought
to call that just the Bone Boat.
It is perfectly fine
to use your hibachi indoors.
A lot of mother (bleep)
don't know that.
Also, they just put
a fresh coat of-- uh...
what's that (bleep) called?--
asbestos in here last week.
Oh, this (bleep) is safe, man.
Safe as can be.
We're gonna do some
bicentennial predictions.
-(quietly): All right!
-You know, um...
this is just the way
I see (bleep)
for the next 200 years.
The Russians will be
the first ones on Venus.
That's my prediction.
What do you think? Mars?
-Uh...
-(bleep) Mars, man.
Future leader, right?
O.J. Simpson.
Man will evolve
to having a third hand.
I don't know where
that hand's gonna come from.
Strangulation will be the way
most people will die.
-Yeah.
-Mm. Tell me it's not more fun
to strangle a (bleep)
than to shoot 'em.
Am I right?
Remember?
You strangled Carl last year.
No, I never told...
(bleep) nobody's watching this
that's gonna arrest you!
He strangled Carl, man.
That was some (bleep).
(Lange laughs)
Man, you just knocked over
my mustard, mother (bleep).
Let me tell you,
let me tell you,
that Liberty Bell, that was
an out-of-sight idea, man.
Nobody cares about no bell,
but you put a crack in it,
all of a sudden everybody wants
to go to Philly and see it.
Right? Like some kind
of tourist attraction.
That's-that's
some genius (bleep).
They ought to put a crack
in everything.
Crack.
Hmm. Hmm.
Have a happy and safe
Fourth of July, America!